[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la joie ses bottes conclure à un
discours en parlant de la joie en
politique et où sa vie ce qui nous
touche le plus dans cette campagne avec
françois-xavier quand on vient ensemble
meeting après meeting avec à votre
rencontre
c'est ce sentiment qui est notre
meilleure récompense que vous avez
retrouvé de l'envié que vous avez
retrouvé de l'enthousiasmé qu'on a
retrouvé du plaisir qu'on a retrouvé
cette volonté qui nous unit quelles que
soient les différences qui sont entre
nous deux d'abord porté les convictions
et la vision commune de la france et de
l'europe qui est la nôtre je vous avais
promis qu'on retrouverait ça je vous
avais promis que notre reconstruction
nous amènerait là et ce qui est sans
doute là qui le plus fort pour nous de
cette campagne européenne
c'est d'avoir réussi à retrouver d'abord
cette fierté de nos valeurs des
convictions de la droite et du centre et
de l'avoir fait en se rassemblant et en
se retrouvant ensemble merci à tous de
nous avoir un psy et de porter cette
campagne et les dé prendre soin xavier
dans ce moment yvan toi qui est l'ami
fidèle et loyal dans cette région où j'y
pensais quand guillaume liste et chaque
mot ou chaque département est le nom
d'une page d'aventuré d'histoire à lui
tout seul que l'on mailles du béarn
jusqu'aux confins du poitou charentes
patrick toi qui incarne la loyauté la
constance dans cette région je sais il
ya parfois eu des vents contraires et où
il ya parfois eu beaucoup de troubles et
je suis d'une profonde reconnaissance à
chacun d'entre vous d'être resté aux
côtés de notre famille politique dans
cette période en une reconnaissance qui
va du premier de nos députés didier en
passant par nos sénateurs nombreux par
nos élus régionaux départementaux
municipaux mais jusqu à chacun d'entre
vous qui êtes les militants de notre
famille politique et qui nous rappeler
une chose en politique les âmes ne sont
pas avant
en politique les âmes mortes ne sont pas
à acheter une des choses que je reproche
sans doute le plus à en marche c'est
d'avoir constitué au fond une politique
faite de mercenaires où l'on débauche
les gens en leur offrant des postes aux
républicains dans la droite et le centre
les armes ne sont pas achetées et je
veux devant vous exprimer ma gratitude à
françois xavier pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ne l'aviez pas écouté jusque là
maintenant vous savez vous savez
pourquoi j'ai fait ce choix
vous savez pourquoi j'ai tenu à faire ce
choix choix qui n'a pas été toujours
facile au début
à faire partager parce qu'il était
surprenant mais en politique les joies
face ils ne sont jamais les bons choix
et le moment je savais et où j'ai su que
c'était évidemment le bon pari est plus
qu'un pari où c'était la seule manière
de tirer la politique vers le haut c'est
quand il ya eu ce débat france
télévisions et où chacune des têtes de
listes devaient exhumé un objet qui
incarnait sa vision profonde de ce qu'il
voulait faire en politique
le tête de liste du rassemblement
national avait sorti une passoire rouge
1 têtes de liste dont je ne connais même
plus le nom avait exhumé une paire de
menottes sur laquelle il s'était
astreint à coller des petits
autocollants jaunes la tête de liste en
mars c'est sans doute d'ailleurs une des
dernières fois où ils ont accepté de lui
laisser la parole avait sorti une boîte
de piment d'espelette et françois-xavier
lui avait sorti un livre et qu'elle
livre l'iliade d'homère merci à françois
xavier de redonner de la dignité et du
sens à la politique
nous le faisons semblait dit nous
faisons ensemble avec cpnt nous le
faisons ensemble avec hervé morin et
n'oubliez jamais seul à la droite
rassemble quand elle assume ses valeurs
et ses idées la droite quand elle baisse
le regard quand elle marche à l'ombre
quand elle s'excuse
elle ne rassemble pas ce que nous avons
fait dans cette campagne c'est que nous
avons réussi à rassembler il y a deux
jours nous étions tous ensemble avec
valérie pécresse avec gérard larcher
avec bruno retailleau avec christian
jacob
avec tous les parlementaires et tout le
monde et être ensemble
et bien c'est cette image que j'aime
pour notre famille politique il y avait
expliqué ce message que françois-xavier
veut porter avec toute l'équipe
je voudrais juste m'arrêter sur quelque
chose qui est tout à la fois extrêmement
révélateur est assez choquant la façon
dont au fond le président de la
république le premier ministre
la totalité des membres de son
gouvernement insultes régulièrement la
france de droite le premier ministre
encore très régulièrement s'en est pris
vous l'avais dit à la france du
trocadéro il y a hier ils s'en prenaient
en expliquant la droite qui se paye de
mots mais quelle étrange comportement
qu'elle est trans premier ministre que
celui ci qui donne tellement de leçons à
tout le monde lui qui a rejoint le
président de la république en étant
caché à l'arrière d'une voiture avec une
couverture sur la tête
conduite par monsieur benalla et
malheureusement l'anecdote est véritable
quelle étrange premier ministre et
qu'elle est trans président de la
république que celui qui prédestine aux
destinées de la france et qui croient
qu'on peut le faire
en insultant ceux qui ne partagent pas
vos idées quelle étrange président de la
république que celui qui insulte
régulièrement le peuple de la droite et
du centre
quelle étrange premier ministre qui dit
ne pas aimer la droite trocadéro mais
s'il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro
c'est parce qu'il n'aime pas la droite
du tout c'est parce qu'il n'y a plus
rien en lui de droite c'est parce que
tout ce qu'ils font depuis deux ans ne
correspond pas aux valeurs de la droite
et du centre
voilà ce qui gêne en réalité le premier
ministre parce que quand on est de
droite
on a le courage de baisser la dépense
publique et de réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires pas ceux qui sont dans
les services publics mais ceux qui
aboutissent à cette bureaucratie qui
petit à petit est en train d'étouffer
notre pays sous le poids des normes des
contraintes et de l'absurdité que
dénonçait déjà peuple ville quand on est
de droite
on ne nie pas l'existence d'une culture
française comme l'a fait le président de
la république on ne va pas dans un pays
comme l'algérie en expliquant que la
france n'aurait commis que des crimes
contre l'humanité et en humiliant ainsi
notre pays de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée quand on est de droite on
ne dit pas comme l'a fait la tête de
liste en marche que le voile islamique
n'a pas de différence de nature avec les
soi-disant fichu qu'aurait portée nos
grands-mères en allant dans les églises
et en ne comprenant pas ainsi la
nécessité du combat que nous avions
amené quand on est de droite
on a du respect pour ceux qui vous ont
précédés pour ceux qui ont travaillé et
qui l'on fait souvent dans des
conditions qui étaient bien plus
difficile que celle de notre génération
quand on est de droite on ne dit pas que
les retraités sont des privilégiés comme
l'a fait le président de la république
et on ne leur prend pas huit milliards
d'euros en deux ans quand on est de
droite on n'accepte pas de faire rentrer
année après année plus d'immigrés alors
que nos capacités d'intégration sont
dépassés quand on est de droite on ne
met pas sur sa liste quelqu'un comme
pascal durand en position éligible qui a
osé dire et comparer un terroriste
palestinien nelson mandela pour en faire
l'éloge quel trouble des repères et
quels troubles de la vision et enfin mes
amis et dans cette région vous le savez
plus que tout
quand on est de droite sa liste n'est
pas soutenu par cohn bendit
elisabeth guigou ségolène royal est
quelqu'un comme pascal canfin
tout ceci ressemble de plus en plus à
une nouvelle majorité de gauche
plurielle beaucoup plus qu'à une liste
de droite
cette liste n'est pas de droite cette
liste ne correspond pas aux valeurs de
la droite et du centre
et je vous demande de le dire autour de
vous que tous ceux qui en france partage
les idées de la droite et du centre
fasse le choix de la seule liste qui est
un choix clairement pour l'europe et qui
le fait en défendant les valeurs de la
droite et du centre c'est celle des
républicains oui notre liste croix dans
l'europe
notre liste croix dans la vision de
notre liste croient plus que jamais dans
la nécessité d'une europe une europe qui
protège nos frontières une europe qui
défendent notre identité face à
l'islamisme
une europe qui acceptent le bras de fer
face à l'été face aux états unis et à la
chine une europe des projets l'europe
que nous aimons cette europe
ça n'est incontestablement pas celle de
la voie du rassemblement national et de
marine le pen
pourquoi est-ce que je combats marine le
pen dans cette élection je la combat
pour une seule raison c'est parce que ce
qu'elle porte c'est un projet de
déconstruction de l'europe
je la combat pour une seule raison c'est
parce que ce qu'elle porte c'est un
projet de déconstruction de l'euro et
j'invite chacun de nos compatriotes à
regarder ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
de la manche et à comprendre que ce
projet serait sans doute la pire erreur
historique pour notre pays
au royaume uni ce sont des gens qui ont
voté en écoutant exactement les mêmes
discours que ceux de marine le pen et
qui se réveille ensuite en se disant
mais comment avons nous pu plonger notre
pays dans un tel chaos dans un tel chaos
et dans cette campagne il ya quelque
chose qui est très marquant les extrêmes
se retrouvent et marine le pen est
maintenant soutenue par toute une partie
des élus qui viennent de l'extrême
gauche et de mélenchon et de la france
insoumise et cela nous rappelle une
seule chose mais que nous ne devons
jamais oublier
marine le pen n'est pas de droite marine
le pen est juste des extrêmes de tous
les extrêmes
c'est la seule chose qui la caractérise
elle est l'incarnation de cette volonté
de rassembler l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche il n'y a rien pour nous
qui corresponde aux chemins qui peuvent
être les nôtres mais cette voie n'est
pas non plus celle d' emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron propose toujours plus de
l'europe qui n'a pas marché
l'europe de la technocratie l'europe de
l'élargissement l'europe multiculturelle
l'europe qui ne comprend pas qu'il faut
retrouver des projets et non des normes
l'europe qui s'épuise dans
l'élargissement et surtout lui qui se
prétendait être un grand européen
comment at il pu ainsi isoler la france
jamais sans doute depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale
la relation franco allemande n'a été
aussi abîmé
jamais depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
une chancelière allemande n'a utilisé
des termes aussi durs pour décrire la
réalité de la capacité de travail
qu'elle avait avec un président de la
république qu'elle ne comprenait pas et
avec lequel elle n'arrivait pas à
avancer
quand angela merkel dit qu'elle a des
relations conflictuelles avec notre
président de la république jamais ça
n'est arrivé dans l'histoire des
relations franco allemandes de gaulle et
adenauer n'aurait jamais utilisé ce
terme
giscard d'estaing et schmitt cela ne
leur venaient même pas la tête
françois mitterrand helmut kohl avait
conscience de leurs responsabilités eux
qui étaient pourtant si différents et il
avait pu travailler ensemble
chirac et schröder ont oeuvré ensemble
nicolas sarkozy et angela merkel ont
travaillé en confiance françois hollande
et en gala merkel ont travaillé en
confiance c'est la première fois qu'un
président de la république
abymes à ce point et l'europe et la
relation franco-allemande et pourquoi
c'est grave
pas parce que nous devons être tout le
temps d'accord avec l'allemagne mais
parce que si la france et l'allemagne ne
se mettent pas d'accord
rien ne peut avancer en europe art.r il
se prétend européens mais dans quel état
va-t-il laisser l'europe
il a fragmenté la france et il est en
train de fragmenter l'europe
il nous a mis à dos l'allemagne il nous
a mis à dos tous les peuples d'europe
centrale
il nous a mis à dos les pays de la
baltique en leur faisant la leçon il
nous a mis à dos l'italie il nous a mis
à dos les pays du benelux jamais sans
doute dans l'histoire européenne
la voix de la france a pesé aussi peu et
nous n'avons été aussi isolé et bien je
vous le dis le vote utile pour l'europe
c'est le vote pour les républicains
pour l'union de la droite et du centre
pour le parti populaire européen
[Applaudissements]
l'europe
que font les pères fondateurs
quand ils choisissent un symbole il met
sur ce drapeau quoi les étoiles de la
couronne de la vierge
c'est notre symbole c'est ce drapeau
c'est le drapeau européen
ou de gaulle et adenauer décide de se
retrouver au moment où ils veulent
sceller la réentendre franco-allemande
et bâtir la possibilité de donner un
nouvel élan en europe pas à bruxelles
pas à berlin pas à paris
ils le font devant la cathédrale de
reims devant cette statue admirable de
lens au sourire qui avait été détruite
par les bombardements allemands et il
signifie dans ce moment là que c'est au
coeur de ce que l'histoire européenne a
de mieux celle de ses racines
chrétiennes qu'ils vont édifier la
réconciliation franco allemande
voilà ce qu'ils font et ce qu'ils font
l'un et l'autre ce qu'on fait les pères
fondateurs ceux qui notamment à travers
monnaie ont grandi à l'ombre de cette
région et bien ce qu'ils font c'est un
projet de civilisation
une civilisation ce qu'ils font ça n'est
pas une construction administrative ils
veulent porter quoi ils veulent porter
cette idée qu au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale la voix de l'europe
n'est pas éteinte qu'elle peut connaître
un souffle pourquoi êtes vous là au fond
parce que chacun d'entre nous nous
sommes habités par la même question
allons-nous devoir changer de mode de
vie
allons-nous quitté le train de
l'histoire nous qui l'avons fait pendant
tant de siècles
sommes nous condamnés à laisser à nos
enfants un continent qui reculent allons
nous assister maintenant spectateurs au
fait que ce sera tout à la fois google
et les dirigeants chinois qui vont
dicter ce que sera l'avenir de mes deux
enfants louise et baptiste est ce cela
ce destin que nous voulons ou est-ce
qu'au contraire ne sommes nous pas là
parce que nous sommes convaincus que
tout ce que nous sommes permet un avenir
à condition que nous l'assumons et que
nous en retrouverons la fierté une
civilisation l'europe encore tente à
dire pour la marche du monde
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
civilisation quand romulus fondre sommes
que fait-il il trace un sillon
et parce sion ils marquent clairement
les limites de la cité et il dit que
c'est lui qui décidera qui rentre ou qui
ne rentrent pas une civilisation c'est
d'abord des frontières ce sont des
limites
pourquoi avons nous affaiblit l'europe
parce que nous nous sommes trop élargi
il faut mettre un terme à
l'élargissement et c'est sans doute une
de nos différences majeures majeur avec
le programme des manuels macron emmanuel
macron accepte d'ouvrir les négociations
avec l'albanie en juin il a expliqué que
la roumanie et la bulgarie devait
rentrer le plus vite possible dans
l'espace schengen et il a dit à triaize
que tous les pays des balkans avait et
devait rentrer dans l'union européenne
rapidement nos chacune de nos têtes de
listes chacune de nos figures dans nos
régions et sur la liste s'engage à une
chose ils voteront pendant la totalité
de leurs mandats contre toute décision
qui ouvrirait la voie à un élargissement
supplémentaires avoir des frontières et
les connaître cela suppose ensuite bien
sûr de savoir mais défendre
c'est même la première vocation de ce
qu'on attend d'une construction
politique
montesquieu l'avait d'ailleurs
parfaitement compris dans la filiation
mais je ne peux rien dire devant
françois xavier de obs la première
vocation du politique c'est d'abord de
protéger
c'est notre premier devoir aujourd'hui
nous ne protégeons pas et nous ne
contrôlons pas nos frontières est-ce
qu'elle arrivait le monde va mieux mais
c'est tout l'inversé
comment ne pas comprendre au contraire
que tous ces drames humains dans la
méditerranée auquel personne ne peut
rester insensible sont nourris par ces
faux espoirs que nous faisons lever ou
nous donnons le sentiment que l'avenir
de l'afrique peut-être en europe en nous
donnant le sentiment à toute cette
jeunesse africaine que au mépris des
pires dangers
en faisant le choix du déracinement en
étant parfois instrumentalisée par les
passeurs
ils trouveront de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée un eldorado qui n'existent
pas parce que nos capacités
d'intégration ne le permettent plus la
vraie générosité n'est pas celle là la
vraie générosité c'est celle qui
consiste à dire l'avenir de la jeunesse
africaine doit être en afrique
l'europe doit s'engager pour aider les
pays africains à se développer pour
faire en sorte que les capacités
d'enseignement se développe en afrique
pour faire en sorte que le continent
africain connaissent un nouveau
dynamisme sens c'est notre
responsabilité et c'est celle ci qu'il
faut assumer et quand je voi inverse car
qui franchissent maintenant les pyrénées
et qui arrive à biarritz qui arrive le
long de la côte basque avec ces visages
hagards qui savent parfois même pas où
ils sont cela ça n'est pas la vraie
générosité
c'est pour cette raison que nous voulons
protéger nos frontières il faut les
protéger grâce à l'europe en espagne en
italie en grèce
ce que marine le pen n'a absolument pas
compris et il faut également qu'il
puisse y avoir en plus de cette
protection européenne une protection
nationale et que la france ait la
possibilité de choisir qui rentre ou qui
ne rentrent pas ses ailes parce que ça
n'est pas parce que l'espagne a décidé
de faire des afflux d'immigration et de
faire des afflux de régularisation
qu'ensuite ces décisions doivent
s'imposer à la france nous militons pour
qu'il y ait une double protection de nos
frontières
une protection européenne et une
protection nationale contre
l'immigration irrégulière
nous sommes la seule liste à faire cette
proposition pour qu'il y ait une
civilisation il faut ensuite qu'il y ait
des projets des projets communs et 6
nous avons fait au cours des années qui
se sont écoulées tant de mal à l'europe
c'est sans doute parce qu'on a laissé
les normes se substituer au projet et
parce que nous en france parce que nous
sommes le pays de la folie des normes
nous avons eu cette démesure de croire
que parce que nous étions plus
intelligent que les autres à chaque fois
qu'il y avait une norme
tous les autres pays prennent la norme
la moins exigeante et nous nous prenons
la norme la plus folle la france a une
lourde responsabilité parce qu'elle a
systématiquement surenchérit par rapport
aux normes européennes
retrouvons le bon sens retrouvant la
simplicité retrouvons la retenue le
politique ne doit pas tout régime hanter
le politique ne doit pas tout diriger à
l'arrivée en décourage tout ceux qui
veulent entreprendre tous ceux qui
veulent faire tous ceux qui prennent des
initiatives tout aussi bien nos
agriculteurs nos commerçants les
professions libérales et ceux qui dans
ce pays entreprennent prennent des
risques et embauche la france à laquelle
nous croyons l'europe à laquelle nous
croyons c'est l'europe du travail
l'europe de la vraie solidarité par le
travail par celle de l'assistanat
l'europe qui sait que pour aider
quelqu'un il faut l'aider à le remettre
sur le chemin du travail
et vous le savez j'ai toujours milité
pour qu'en contrepartie du rsa
nous proposions systématiquement des
heures de travail d'intérêt général
obligatoires
parce que c'est la meilleure manière
d'aider les gens et parce que ça c'est
la vraie solidarité s'être plan ne peut
pas être uniquement l'europe du
consommateur
je ne veux pas
comme dessein pour notre pays pour notre
continent qu'on se retrouve juste à
pousser des caddies dans les
supermarchés où tout a été fabriqué
ailleurs j'ai beaucoup de mal à
comprendre que les chinois puissent
venir chez nous acheter des terres
achetées les entreprises copiées nos
brevets etc en revanche nous nous ne
puissions acheté aucune terre en chine
aucun vignoble en chine
aucune entreprise en chine que eux
puissent venir copier nos secrets
regarder ce que nous font le fabriquer
ensuite chez eux puis ensuite le
revendre chez nous et que nous soyons
même incapable de prendre la moindre
mesure pour dire stop
vous n'avez pas le droit de faire chez
nous ce que nous ne pouvons pas faire
chez vous eh bien oui
nous réclamons le fait de dire finie la
naïveté européenne dans le rapport avec
la chine et s'être plan ne peut pas être
l'europe où tout est à acheter
la dignité humaine n'est pas à vendre
la dignité de l'homme la dignité de la
femme n'est pas acheté il ya des limites
que l'on doit poser face aux progrès de
la science cela s'appelle l'éthique
cela s'appelle la morale cela s'appelle
cette conviction qui est si proprement
européenne consistant à dire que tout
n'est pas possible que l'homme ne peut
pas devenir un dieu qu'il ne peut pas
tout choisir que tout ne peut pas être
génétiquement modifiés que tout ne peut
pas être trafiquées qu'il y à aussi un
respect que nous devons avoir par
rapport à ce qui nous a été transmis que
dans cette époque où l'on parle tant de
développement durable l'homme aussi est
une espèce humaine dont il faut
respecter les règles et le mode de
reproduction et le mode de transmission
tout ne peut pas être altéré tout ne
peut pas être changé
et je respecte toutes les opinions mais
je ne veux pas qu'elle soit fait en
étant caché la tête de liste en marche a
très clairement dit qu'elle était
favorable à la gestation pour autrui
c'est à dire aux mères porteuses
c'est à dire au fait de louer le ventre
d'une femme pour que l'on puisse enfanté
un enfant est qu'à sa naissance cette
enfant soit confiée à quelqu'un d'autre
ça n'est pas conforme à ce qu'est notre
vision ça n'est pas conforme à ce que
nous voulons pour l'avenir de notre
civilisation européenne nous nous
battrons pour faire en sorte que ce ne
soit pas c'est voilà qu'ils se fassent
entendre au parlement européen
nous nous battrons pour faire rêver
inscrire dans notre été la protection de
la dignité humaine et le refus de la
marchandisation du corps humain est une
civilisation enfin c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus précieux de plus fragiles ses
larmes
c'est ce petit bout de culture
d'histoire qui en chacune de nos
mémoires que nous en soyons d'ailleurs
conscient ou non cette civilisation et
les mortels cette civilisation et les
fragiles
cette civilisation aujourd'hui certains
veulent l'abattre
comment ne pas comprendre que les
terroristes islamistes
parfois même ceux qui sont nés sur le
sol français sur le sol européen ceux
auxquels l'europe et la france ont tout
donné avec une immense générosité et qui
ont tourné leur armes et leur haine
contre no comment ne pas comprendre que
ce qu'ils veulent détruire c'est tout ce
qu'incarne tout à la fois la france et
l'europe
comment peut-on faire preuve d'une telle
naïveté au moment du xxème siècle quand
la république instaure la laïcité
elle demande à l'église catholique de
faire des efforts pour respecter les
règles de la laïcité et faire en sorte
que nous puissions vivre en commun et
l'église catholique accepte d'adapter
son mode de fonctionnement pour faire en
sorte que la république puisse se
construire sur le respect de chacune des
consciences et c'est les règles de la
laïcité et aujourd'hui nous acceptons
silencieusement que ces mêmes règles de
la laïcité
elle toute une partie des français au
début du 20e siècle avait accepté de se
soumettre soit aujourd'hui détourné
utilisé par la propagande islamiste pour
retourner contre la france sa propre dit
identité et ses propres armes et nous ne
réagissons pas et dans le programme dans
marche le mot islamisme n'est même pas
verbalisés eh bien nous nous avons le
courage et la simplicité de le dire un
des plus grands combats qui attend
l'europe demain c'est le combat contre
l'islamisme
parce que c'est en deux parties de ce
combat dans lequel se jouera l'avenir de
notre identité de notre continent et
nous le disons avec la plus grande
clarté il faut qu'il y ait un pacte
européen contre l'islamisme ce pacte
européen contre l'islamisme doit amener
à fermer toutes les mosquées salafistes
qui sont en europe parce que ces
mosquées font un travail pour propager
la haine et le refus de l'autre ce pacte
européen contre l'islamisme doit
permettre de dire que quentin imams
prêchent la haine chaque vendredi il ne
doit pas rester en europe et il doit
être reconduit à l'extérieur de nos
frontières
parce qu'il a trahi ce qu'était l'esprit
de l'europe et de notre civilisation
[Applaudissements]
vous allez sur les djihadistes je me
suis rendu à mossoul
ma région un programme de soutien des
minorités chrétiennes qui sont en irak
et en syrie
j'ai vu
ce qu'était le travail de destruction
des jihadistes j'ai vu leur barbarie
dans les yeux de ces familles zidi qui
ont été réduits en esclavage sexuel
j'ai vu le reflet de la barbarie des
djihadistes dans les yeux de ce père de
famille
croisé au milieu des ruines de mossoul
qui avaient perdu tous ses enfants une
famille de sept enfants massacrés par
les djihadistes parce qu'il ne
partageait pas la religion j'ai vu leur
fait cette barbarie à l'ombre de ce
building où il faisait monter leurs
victimes avec un sac sur la tête pour
les précipiter duo et pour qu'ils
agonise au pied de ce building
ces jihadistes sont des barbares et le
gouvernement et le président de la
république a accepté de faire revenir
200 jihadiste sur le sol français
nous nous demandons une chose qui est
pourtant simple
nous demandons que l'europe prenne
l'initiative d'organiser un tribunal
européen internationale en irak que ce
tribunal international permettent de
juger en irak
les djihadistes qu'ils permettent de les
condamner en irak et qu'ils permettent
surtout qu'ils restent en irak et en
syrie là où ils ont commis leur crime et
qu'il ne revienne pas sur le sol
européen
[Applaudissements]
mais françois xavier a posé la bonne
question
il a posé la vraie question comment en
est on arrivé là
ici vous le savez et je suis sûr que
dans cette salle bien des personnes
pourraient en témoigner
l'histoire de la france et de la
république a longtemps été une
extraordinaire histoire d'intégration
je suis sûr qu ici bien des figures
pourrait se lever et témoigner de ce
qu'est leur propre parcours familial des
familles qui étaient venus au moment de
la guerre civile en france y sont les
pyrénées les familles venues du portugal
pour travailler des familles venues de
pologne du nord de la france d'italie
des familles venues du sud de la
méditerranée et qui était venu ici
d'afrique en s'inscrivant dans ce
qu'était cette grande tradition de
l'intégration française dans laquelle
celui qui vient vient pour travailler
dans la quête celui qui vient disait à
ses enfants
à compter de ce jour ton pays c'est la
france travaille dur à l'école apprend
le français ne me fait pas honte
écoutez m fais-toi respectable en étant
respecté apprend un travail devient
l'honneur et la fierté de ta famille ça
c'est l'histoire de l'intégration
française une histoire dans laquelle on
enseignait à ceux qui venaient chez nous
ce qu'était notre histoire
ce qu'était notre tradition ce
qu'étaient nos grands hommes de lettres
parce que dans la nation française les
hommes de lettres sont des figures qui
nous dirigent et qui nous éclairent seul
pays sans doute à placer à ce point là
sa confiance dans ce qu'ils écrivent et
que cela est il devenu
comment avons nous pu inverser le devoir
d'intégration
comment avons nous pu arriver à linverse
comment avons nous pu arriver à ce stade
où nous croyons qu'à cueillir l'autre
c'est accepter que ce soit nous qui
devions
changer notre mode de vie comment avons
nous pu perdre de vue le fait que c'est
exactement le contraire qu'il faut cette
leçon ne l'avons nous pas tous ressenti
quand on a vu notre dame de france brûlé
quand notre dame à brûler tout d'un coup
tout le monde a compris que nous soyons
croyants que nous ne soyons pas que nous
soyons chrétiens ou que ne le soyons pas
cet être un bout de la france qui
brûlait et pourquoi est ce que c'était
un bout de la france qui brûlaient mais
parce que bien évidemment c'est est un
des plus beaux joyaux une des plus belle
incarnation de tout ce qui a été le
patient travail d'édification de la
france ce travail qui si vous connaissez
parfaitement ce travail qui a amené
cette ville de bordeaux à être une des
incarnations les plus parfaites de
l'esprit français
cette ville de bordeaux fondée par un
des lieutenants de jules césar crassus
qui ont fait la capitale de cette
province romaine et qui trace déjà le
plan de l'urbanisme romain cette ville
de bordeaux qui est ensuite fondé à
travers ses racines chrétiennes
une deuxième fois quand le pape vient
ici et qu'il consacre la cathédrale
saint-andré cette ville de bordeaux qui
ensuite a été l'incarnation de cette
extraordinaire esprit tout à la fois des
renaissance et des lumières qui amène la
france à faire confiance sans renier ses
racines chrétiennes dans l'esprit du
progrès et dans l'esprit de la science
et à devenir ainsi une des villes
éclairé de notre pays
cette ville qui peut s'enorgueillir
quand on parle d'un maire de dire ici
michel de montaigne et est un maire
cette ville qui peut s'enorgueillir
d'avoir vu ces deux grands esprits
français montaigne et montesquieu qui
dialoguait de part et d'autre de la
renaissance et de l'esprit des lumières
cette ville de bordeaux qui a eu
l'audace de partir à la conquête du
monde est aujourd'hui dans une époque où
il paraît qu'il ne faut plus cités
colbert et qu'il faut bannir les bustes
de colbert
mais quelle profonde erreur de juger les
temps passés à l'aune de nos idées
d'aujourd'hui
oui on peut être fier de ce qu'ont fait
les bordelais quand ils sont partis à la
conquête du monde
oui ils ont à l'époque fait preuve
d'audace et ils ont construit les balles
que ce qu'était le rayonnement de
bordeaux et une partie de la fierté
française que des erreurs et été
commises bien sûr mais qu'il faille
ensuite donné cette image terrible où la
france ne cesse de s'excuser de son
histoire
au lieu d'en transmettre la fierté et la
reconnaissance aux générations
d'aujourd'hui quel profonde erreur
soyez fiers de bordeaux soyez fiers de
vos industries conquérante soyez fiers
des nouvelles technologies d'aujourd'hui
et soyez fiers de vos racines soyez fier
de tout ce que vous incarnez soyez fiers
de ce territoire de nouvelles aquitaine
et bien la leçon de notre dame de france
est ce là il y à des incendies visible
et il y à des incendies invisible une
civilisation peut partir à travers ses
monuments et elle peut partir quand on
renonce quand on se soumet et quand on
recule
à chaque fois qu'on renonce à enseigner
notre histoire de france à nos enfants
dans nos classes c est un incendie à
chaque fois que l'on accepte que dans un
quartier une femme ne puissent plus
choisir son destin professionnel ou la
façon dont elle veut se vêtir 7
un incendie à chaque fois que nous
renonçons à une petite parcelle de ce
que nous sommes
7 un incendie pourquoi je n'ai jamais
voulu reculer sur cette question en
apparence si anodine des crèches
parce que je suis convaincu que les
crèches est un petit bout de ce que nous
sommes et parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on
recule même sur un petit bout infime de
ce que nous sommes c'est un bout de
notre civilisation que l'empoignade et
qu on va s abat alors oui mes amis soyez
fiers de cette histoire en france
l'histoire c'est tout à la fois quelque
chose dont on peut être fier et dont on
doit être digne
soyons fiers de notre histoire et
rappelons cette belle leçon de
saint-augustin à rome fais comme les
romains en france en europe ce n'est pas
à nous de nous adapter à celui qui vient
de l'étranger c'est salutaire c'est à
celui
qui vient de l'étranger de s'adapter à
ce qu'est le mode de vie du pays et du
continent qui l'a choisi c'est cette
fierté que nous voulons retrouver
c'est cette refondation de l'europe que
nous voulons retrouver
c'est ce rétablissement de la france que
nous voulons retrouver françois xavier a
besoin de vous il a besoin de vous pour
nous aider à transformer cet espoir en
un mouvement qui ne s'arrêtera pas il a
besoin de vous pour faire en sorte que
dans cette campagne des européennes nous
puissions à nouveau faire entendre les
valeurs et les convictions qui sont les
nôtres il nous reste huit jours
il vous reste huit jours pour nous aider
à convaincre
il vous reste huit jours pour faire le
choix des convictions il vous reste huit
jours pour montrer oui que dans cette
campagne on n'élimine pas mais ont
choisi par rapport à ce qu'on veut il
vous reste huit jours pour mener le plus
beau des combats
je n'en connais pas de plus beau en
france je n'en connais pas de plus beau
en europe
c'est le combat de l'identité c'est le
combat de la civilisation c'est le
combat qui consiste à refonder l'europe
et à rétablir la france doublera et vive
la france